sister Rani let's take tells us that the
small SUVs are a big hit in Europe with
a cx-3 Mazdas going on the offensive in
the b-segment it's a mixture of the
mazda 2 and the cx-5 and he's going to
find out where the cx-3 can do a major
part of mazda's efficiency strategy is
its so-called sky active technology
which encompasses motors gears chassis
and the cars bodies all see x3 models
came with a standard start/stop system
and the bigger engine models also have a
standard condenser system for recycling
energy released when braking in terms of
the motor mazda is bucking the trend of
increasing efficiency by decreasing
cubic capacity but it been mazda press
spokesman yahan one singer tells us that
the car maker still features high
capacity ancients this model has a high
compression 2 liter engine that means
that this engine is more efficient
especially in real driving conditions
than down size turbo ones and despite
the fact that these are only aspirated
engines they have good linear torque
development so they're really nice to
drive the auditor element and positive
lesson is the onion and fawn the two
liter gasoline direct injection engine
comes in an 88 kilowatt front-wheel
drive version and a 110 kilowatt
all-wheel drive option we're testing the
more powerful model it goes from 0 to
100 kilometers an hour in 8.7 seconds
and on average consumes just 6.4 litres
of fuel per 100 kilometers
I didn't see her car tipster says the
first time he saw the car he was
somewhat skeptical but once he got in it
won him over it features quality
synthetic suede and leather the sight
lines are perfect and drivers have no
problems pulling out of parking spots or
passing other cars like all mazda models
the exterior of the cx-3 is inspired by
Cotto design which focuses on the use of
visual energy a crucial element are the
striking lines the cx-3 also has an
extended hood with a driver's cab moved
back
the black d pillars give the car a sleek
silhouette the beatin yo convince eager
tells us that mazda offers both front
wheel and all wheel drives which is not
always the case in this price class the
cx-3 has a six gear automatic
transmission and customers can choose
among a broad range of options last but
not least the car has a brilliant
exterior and a minimalist but
high-quality interior that's also not a
given in this price segment the interior
emphasis is clarity and ergonomics
the driver's seat is adjustable for a
variety of needs and the cx-3 offers
loads of leg and shoulder room
the mcd connect system allows drivers to
use the internet it's operated with
buttons in the middle of the console the
cx-3 also comes in a diesel model either
with or without all-wheel drive the
starting sticker price is seventeen
thousand nine hundred ninety euros for
the small engine the gas powered model
makes the Mazda cx-3 a serious
competitor for the BMW x1 and Audi q3
our tester was amazed at how little fuel
it consumed the SKYACTIV technology
features a condensed motor instead of a
turbo engine which means that the car
only burns an average of six point four
liters per 100 kilometers his conclusion
the Mazda cx-3 is a good b-segment SUV
that's sure to find lots of fans